are you guys doing good how are you sir
I'm just to let you know that Collider
does have more money but we just only
felt that you guys deserve two three
mics instead of five okay cuz we we only
feel like only three of us deserve to
talk but we're not going to tell you
which three so uh I have a million
questions but I'm gonna start with I'm
I'm curious how do you guys cuz there's
so many people working on this movie so
many departments so many people doing
the VFX how do you keep track of who is
doing what and more importantly how does
it never leak I'm shocked that none of
these shots or you know what I mean ever
get out you're making me panic a lot of
people it's we do say it's like a
consortium of generals and you're
looking at a part of that consortium
right now is it you know they're there a
lot of you know key collaborative
individuals that it takes to make
something of the scale I you know the
great thing with us is that you know we
have sort of a roomful of trusted
advisors that we work with that includes
everyone sitting here and then they each
have thousands of people working
underneath them that they have to
communicate efficiently with about
storytelling the sensitivity to
character and you know in a film like
this that is filled with CG characters
and one in particular being fan of who
has to you know in a lot of ways carry
the emotional center of the movie we
have said this before it is his film and
he's exclusively CG and you know I would
argue that I don't know that that's ever
been done before on the scale and we're
you know that level of emotion was
conveyed to an audience that they have
the hardest task of anyone making sure
that the humanity and the storytelling
stays consistent from shot to shot
throughout the movie so maybe you guys
can talk a little bit about how do you
communicate with your teams yeah I think
it's you know starting out it'll be for
production side we've got a small army
of people that track all the shots right
and it's something that you know you'll
you cast the different visual effects
houses based on what their specialties
are so and on infinity where we had 14
different visual effects houses working
on the film and so based on you know the
daily processes you know shots come in
from the visual effects houses they're
kind of checked in their track
throughout the day we sit in dailies all
day long in the darkroom and review them
all send notes out and then send them
back back out to the visual effects
houses yeah and then then we get those
notes we sit in another screening room
all day long and go over the notes and
new stuff that's coming in that we make
either notes to send with delivery notes
and like it's this big back and forth
collaboration and what's really exciting
about the scope and size of this project
is like how many shots total twenty-two
thousand six hundred and twenty three
and there's two thousand seven hundred
and three in the movie so there's 80
shots we didn't actually work on so 97
percent of the film was has visual
effects if I hoped if I can just follow
up though I am amazed though on a movie
like this with so many thousands of
people and companies working on it that
nothing ever gets out or all these
computers have air gaps like what's the
death and I think there's just a code of
ethics within the industry this goes not
just for people working on visual
effects but crew members onset location
shoots what-have-you any member of the
film crew all the way through post
production pre-production you know you
this is what your job is and if you are
going leak stuff you're not going to be
doing it for very long that's it's
pretty simple I should warn you if you
ask any more questions about our
security your name is going to show a
list no but I'm constantly amazed though
it ends up inevitably that the leaks
come out when Lego releases their toy
images or a toy image more than it's the
people working on the film you know
that's how things get out interesting
about toy leaks is that 99% of the time
they're not accurate because toys are
frankly tailored to either like
concepts were completely different
concepts than what's in the movie I'm a
lot when those toy leaks show up cuz I'm
like well that's great because it's
misdirect because it has nothing to do
with the film so you know frankly the
the the very essential nature of the
storytelling is contained within you
know the brains and computers of all the
great individuals working all the
effects houses on the movie that is with
much more sensitive material and it's
going said the testament to that
industry is he said there's a code of
ethics there and and you know a lot of
sensitive information at least on the
for movies we've worked on us pass
through all of these companies and
nothing's ever leaked I there's a
million things I want to talk about with
the VFX in this movie which are I don't
want to drop an f-bomb but F bomb
incredible so I'm just gonna say but I
wanted to focus on one thing which is
the moon when he grabs the moon and he's
throwing it down which was showing I
think at d23 it's this moment that is
awesome and fans love I want to talk
about from the genesis of that idea to
getting it on screen can you sort of
take us through the process of how
something like that is made I remember
that day that was so we start and previz
well a lot of times we start before the
script and we just gonna start playing
with ideas so you know it's because with
Titan when you kind of do it was like a
lower gravity planet so we would just
start doing motion studies and like how
characters can move and you know what
would it mean for spider-man to swing in
zero-g and that type of thing and and so
as the previous Vols you know we start
telling a narrative and kind of fitting
it into the script and then you know we
can kind of you know how big do we make
the battle and I think we had a review
one day and we showed we were talking to
Joe about it so and Joe and Joe is like
yeah he should like pull the moon out
orbit and it's like okay it's no be
buttoned locked up the shot employing
the moon out of orbit there just came
one of the biggest shots in the film it
is it's crazy we say that we're like you
know we're kids with a really really
expensive lego set that we can anything
you can dream up these guys can make
happen and I think you know ultimately
to it's like what's so valuable about
that though is that they they all are
storytellers
and they understand exactly what we're
trying to accomplish and we've all
collaborated it on several movies
together now and I think that it's
created an amazing an amazingly
consistent level of quality and
exploration and I you know I feel like
and you you think the effects that move
your effort incredible I think they're
often incredible and I we can stand back
and separate ourselves from it because
you know we didn't do all the heavy
lifting on those VFX these guys did and
we could look at it and go that is
exactly our vision as intended relate on
the screen in in in an incredibly
fantastical story on a scale that I
don't know you know like I said outside
the Lord of the Rings movies has been
achieved before and with a central
character who is exclusively CG who
carries the emotional arc of the film I
I definitely want to dig down a little
bit more in terms of okay so it's not in
the script that he grabs the planet
that's just an idea thrown out in the
room when you're looking at dailies yeah
well here we I mean we go through a
really exhaustive process of
experimentation I mean the the amount of
ideas that we will explore with this
team here and and and our wider team is
like far beyond what ends up in the
actual film I mean that's you for
instance that's how that's how fan oohs
came to happen to be honest with you you
know we early on in the process Dan came
to us and said that you thought the
technology was finally there to support
like facial caps you mean facial capture
to it to a level that nobody's ever seen
before and that it might work for the
character of Thanos and so we did a test
with the actor Josh Brolin and when Joe
and I saw that test it kind of blew the
whole movie open for us because we
thought my god we can really take this
guy this character to a very subtle
complicated interior place and and and
give him an arc like you would give of a
lead character that's a hero and really
because we had the ability to take a
fantastical creature like him and make
him accessible on a human emotion scale
like never before and I think that again
that is one of the things that came out
of the process of experimentation before
we all go to work for real on the film
in terms of executing what we what we're
set out to do but there's we can give
you there's there's more examples than
you would ever care to hear about ideas
that don't make the movie well the thing
that I find fascinating as you said
earlier I believe there's 80 shots in
the film that do not have VFX which is
like insane you know and I mean what do
you think is there a shot or two in the
film that is people wouldn't realize
there's just heavy VFX in it where it's
like so subtle like something you're
super proud of that maybe doesn't it Sun
hair unheralded if you know what I mean
I think this film I mean you know this
film is oh it's based on its scale I
think you know everything's kind of huge
right I think it's you know I think for
us it's it's you know kind of what aunt
was hitting on it's like when you stop
thinking thinness as a visual effect and
you just start buying him as a lead
character in the movie or like you know
the antagonist of the movie and
believing in his mission and
understanding him and sympathizing him I
think that's kind of what we're proud of
things in this movie you know the
invisible effects and I don't know
there's not really that many scenes that
we got a chance to do them in just
because it's you know you're in what
Conda you're in middle of ear you're in
warm air you're in you know the on the
beginning of the film with the Thor on
the as guardianship you know everything
is everything is the visual effects in
this film and it's it's it's something
that you know as a as a it's kind of a
defining moment in your career getting
to work on something like that it's
pretty amazing when it's this year
you're able to collaborate so much and
to be kind of you know at the you know
kind of a key place and in the
storytelling it's pretty amazing I think
yeah I'm just gonna say the you know
back to what Jonathan said it's just the
storytelling and everyone's a
storyteller and so I think in a film
like this you don't you watch it and
you're just enjoying the story you're
paying attention to the story and it
becomes less about is that is that CG is
that not CG or how did they do it like
is that real is that
not real and it just sort of all you
know I feel like the work in this film
is at a level that that stuff falls away
and you're really just involved in the
story and not so much thinking about how
did they do that or yeah I mean that
being said we work on does a horse farm
in Atlanta and then everything was blown
away and African trees were put in you
know we we kind of planted this entire
field and say okay we can least have
some of the field be part of Wakanda and
then they got trampled and rained on so
you know 20 by 20 feet of the of the
field that's even less sometimes it's
like actually they're you know Titan was
a stage you know not so much invisible
effects but large portions of the movie
were replaced today you know there's a
there's sorry there's there's a shot in
the Macondo beware some of the heroes
dissipate away and you're looking around
and that's the effect in the scene but
the entire field everything field is all
CG the secondary characters and Akoya
and I got to tell you it's insane the
what VFX what you guys did in this movie
what the VFX have now gotten to because
as somebody's watch the movie multiple
times I I don't see these people as a
CGI thing you know like it's they're
just they're they're you know what I
mean it's a I want I want to switch real
quick if you don't mind because I
limited time I'm curious the this for
people who are watching this who have
not seen the movie spoilers there's
something that happens at the end called
the dusting and I'm curious how you
designed what that was gonna look like
and the collaboration you know because
that's that moment needs to be the
shatter fans it needs to you know what I
mean it's it's this iconic moment so
talk a little bit about the design of
the dusting so something we start off a
you watch the film it's kind of the
there's like a signature kind of look
for all the powers of the stones right
as they're kind of used individually and
then mixed together they're always you
know color coded to the stone and kind
of combined in interesting ways and so
when we started with the initial passes
of it we were you know since he was
using all six stones it was something
that initially we tried to kind of keep
that same language happening
everybody turned to dust and and all
that happened it was it just got you
know too many light effects it was kind
of you know the idea that was you know
that there was the dust and there was
kind of a night light interior light
like the soul was there and it just
became something that this ultimately
just stepped on every performance we had
we started with with Tom's performance
when Pete disappears and you know it was
just something that just kind of
shattered what was happening in the
scene so basically the design language
then became you know well what are the
actors feeling in that moment you know
Pete's hanging on as long as he can
write he's kind of and so you're kind of
animating the particles in a way that
you know try to preserve that and you
look at scarlet which fourth Wanda you
know she just lets herself go you know
even so like each each kind of design
once we lost all those extra light
effects and just kind of went with
something that was sympathetic with the
dust of the performances that's
ultimately what is the shattering moment
because each one you know Pete hangs on
Liz you know when she did her
performance just gonna rocks her head
back like she's letting herself go
visions dead she's lost everything in
the world and the particles go away you
know Bucky hangs on until you know his
last look to Steve and then hits the
ground and then you know splatters and
you know splits into the dust and it's
like it's really trying to understand
what the actors were doing and kind of
playing off in the dust itself I'm
curious for you guys when you're on set
and you're directing that you're not
exactly sure I'm gonna imagine you're
not exactly sure what it's going to look
like or did you did you were you far
enough along where you kind of knew what
it would look like when you were
directing it on set I mean we we hadn't
certainly settled on what it would the
final look would be but we had
experimented with I believe at that
point but that's look one of the great
things for Joe and I is you know when
we're as directors when we run said then
one of the miracles of working with Dan
and this visual effects team is that
like we know that we can go almost
anywhere we can change the plan we can
find things that are happening on set
particularly with the actors like Dan
was talking about and we can change
things as we need to on a visual effects
plan / what's happening as we execute
them on a stage as we shoot which is
like an amazing tool for us to have Joe
and I as directors and it really allows
for like a
a huge process even though you do a ton
of work before you ever get to set it
also allows for a huge process process
of discovery on the set while you're
working with the actors while you're
working with these sets that you have
physical adults that allows us to change
course and find opportunities at every
stage of the process I think that's the
trick working with Joe and Anne cuz I
was with Winter Soldier in Civil War I
got to stand behind them for two movies
and like learned everything as much as I
possibly could in the trick with them is
it's giving you know making sure our job
is to give them that environment in
which they can just be creative and just
run and and I think that's hopefully
what we achieved I'm almost out of time
I want to ask a few a few quick
questions did you change anything for
the blu-ray release of the movie was
there like a VFX shot that you're like
oh man we need another second on this
one before it hits the blu-ray yeah we
never stop we never stop were there any
shots that you actually tweaked before
it hit the blu-ray you tune them up a
little bit you wanted you want to
mention which one or no that's right
another thing is so I heard and I could
be wrong that like an earlier cut of the
film had Bruce Banner and the Hulk more
like sort of talking to one another and
what was it where they were more like
working together where they're each
having control is that true or not true
no I mean if you go back in the right
way back in the writing phase you know
for as experimental as we are on a
visual execution level like we've been
speaking about you know we go through
that same process of experimentation
with Markus and McFeely the writers of
the script so we spend many many months
together
talking about different ideas different
ways to take the characters so that
there was there was probably a process
where we went through different ideas
with banner that may have included what
you're talking about but it never really
got mature
yeah where banner may have confronted
the Hulk or something I can't remember
this is three years ago
sure and probably four iterations of the
script I'm sure at some point yeah that
we pitched out we've pitched out a
thousand ideas for what what that movie
could have eventually been and you know
my last two things there quick
what is the you have a movie coming out
a sequel that is you know anticipated I
heard I would imagine you have to finish
it by a certain point so is that date
has to be like in sometime in March I
would imagine there's like a drop date
or it has to be locked are you close
it's actually 5:00 p.m. today I mean is
do you have like that drop date where it
has to be done done we do yeah it's it's
very hard to sit to to say what it is
because there's so many different stages
to the process but essentially we're
done with the movie at the end of March
completely or not Dan yeah it always
gets pushed a weak password Joe and I
are done this is my last thing you
you've said in the past and I have to
ask this because I heard that this could
be and this is it's not a spoiler
question for endgame but it's I heard
this could be the first Marvel movie
that you guys are releasing in three
hours and you've said that before are
you still at the three hour mark is it
close to that yes we're still the three
hour mark right do you think it's equal
day the studio is going to be down with
three out I mean I think the studio is
down with whatever the best story is and
and right now the we you know we think
the movies playing well and and we've
had you know great responses from our
test audiences and we're feeling very
good about where it is we're still doing
work to it yeah we're not done with it
but it is you know again this is a
culmination film you know 22 movies it's
a lot of storytelling to work into it
and
you know emotion is an intrinsic part of
that to us and when you want when you
have to tell a really complicated story
and you want strong emotional moments
for the characters it just requires a
certain amount of real estate and this
one in particular is feels like three
hours worth of real estate I would be
down with the four-hour movie my only
thing is for kids like if you're even
thinking intermission or know I joke
about it the other room but I think
screen the movie four times for
audiences we screen the movie four times
for audiences now so there are people
out there that know how it ends damn
perhaps perhaps but and that for the
first three screenings not a single
person got up to go to the bathroom
say no more I could ask you a million
other questions I'm just going to say
and I mean it's seriously amazing work
on infinity war III give hats off the
visual effects are insane thank you so
much
you